hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but apparently cringe jean-pierre
hasn't gotten better at her job dc mayor
sent the white house a letter asking for
national guard hell
with migrants that have been bused here
from texas and arizona is the president
going to approve that request for the
national guard so as uh to your question
on the national guard i refer you to the
department of defense they will have uh
that answer for you we have been in
regular touch with mayor bowser and her
team uh and i said this before i said
this last week about republicans using
migrants
as a political tool
and that is shameful and that is just
wrong
there is a process in place for managing
migrants at the border this is not it
what they're doing currently that that
includes expelling migrants as required
by court order under title 42
transferring them to ice custody or
placing them in the care of local ngos
as they await for the prop processing
again so what republicans are doing the
way that they're meddling in the process
and using uh migrants as a political
pawn is just wrong so the white house's
preference would be for small towns in
texas and arizona to have to take care
of these migrants rather than a large
metropolitan that is not what i said
washington that is not what i said
i said that there is
yeah they are they're sending migrants
to big cities on purpose using them as a
political point if they don't go to big
cities where should they go
i just laid it out there's a presence
they come to a big city and now this
mayor says she needs the national guard
that's because that's because
republicans are using they're using
migrants
who are coming here
for who knows uh because they are
they're they're dealing with
humanitarian issues back in their
country they're coming here for a better
life and they are being used
peter they're being used by republican
governors that is what's happening let's
just make the president want to say this
is causing a lot of burdens on small
cities big cities maybe i should just
close the border what i'm saying is what
republicans are doing is wrong and there
is a process in place and we should
follow the process there is a legal
process in place and they should follow
it okay thank you